[Music]
we have a lot of cool benchmarks today
we're adding GPU power efficiency
testing so FPS per watt like we did for
CPUs except for gpus it's the debut of
this testing it's not anywhere near
final we have a ton more we can do with
it but we're excited to share that with
you in our 4070 TI super review which is
what this is we also added cyberpunk RT
back in so we have some R tracing
benchmarks with cyberp Punk 2077 we're
planning to add non RT cyberp punk in
the future as well and we're looking
into Alan W too for our next iterative
Edition because we're basically doing
kind of one step at a time let's add
some new types of tests to refresh the
GP reviews because that's what the
manufacturers are doing anyway they're
refreshing it with the Super Series and
amd's got the 7600 XT coming out
tomorrow I don't think I get to go home
tonight or tomorrow night but we'll get
them done let's start with the 4070 TI
super review so I don't have to face
reality which is is that I'm staying
here for a few days this video is
brought to you by us and storu Gamers
access.net for our limited edition
disappointment PCT t-shirt recapping all
the most disappointing Hardware events
of 2023 in a commemorative band style
tour date shirt the front features a
memory stick with an exploded diagram
revealing an accurate representation of
memory while the back features our
limited time tour dates with the best
hits such as snake oil the original 4070
TI launch and a Obsession we still have
every size available in our comfortable
charcoal Heather material but we're
running low fast and we won't be making
another run of these your purchases of
shirts like our charcoal Heather
disappointment shirt help directly fund
our new testing Innovations like GPU FPS
per wat power efficiency and our
recently introduced 3D laser scanner for
testing coolers so head over to store.
Gamers access.net to grab a shirt today
all right the overview so there's a 4070
super we already reviewed that it's on
the channel that's $600 it slots in
alongside the 470 which has dropped
about 50 bucks or so plus or minus a
little bit when this goes up uh then
there's the 470 TI super which is this
one and just as a reminder there's also
a 4070 TI and there's a
470 and then there's the 470 super we
just talked about so we're up to four
4070 cards getting a little confusing
andv video is helping out by
eliminating one of them to think about
the doesn't actually help that much
there's still a lot of 407s and then
there's the 4080 super that is the one
that people in our comments appeared to
be the most excited about or at least
discussing the most when it was all
announced in nvidia's news coverage
that's because it comes down to $11,000
from 1,200 for Baseline uh and that
should be in theory a pretty significant
shift for Value we'll see how it plays
out but it looks a little bit like
Nvidia has maybe couched the less
interesting of these cards between the
two that are potentially more appealing
for value so the 4070 TI super comes in
with a solid meh right in between the
two potentially more appealing cards but
uh there's a lot to talk about today so
a couple of things interesting findings
4K skews higher for the performance
difference between the ti super and the
nons super TI which is because of the
memory subsystem change so the 4070 TI
super we already talked about the specs
in the specs video but it's increased
the memory capacity and in step with
that there's also a memory bandwidth
change memory bus width increase so this
is the entire memory sub system has been
overhauled on the ti super uh and that's
going to reflect more in those higher
memory load scenarios like 4K okay Power
efficiencies first we're not really
going to spend a ton of time setting
this one up so for power efficiency
testing this is something we already
debuted with our CPU bench marks the
video was called Intel problem or
something CP power efficiency and that
looked at primar IL FPS per watt or some
other metric so like mips per watt for
example interestingly FPS per watt could
be simplified into effectively frames
per Jewel cancel the per second cancels
out for both uh and that's what we're
going be looking at now for sake of
using phrases that people are familiar
with and metrics people know watts and
FPS we're going to stick with FPS per
watt but that's kind of the idea the
purpose of FPS per watt testing or
efficiency testing is very simple
typically we'll test a full load power
virus scenario for gpus just like we
test a full load scenario with blender
for CPUs what that misses and what we've
been pretty open about it missing over
the years is gaming workloads which are
not anywhere near that simple it is
never simple with gaming the reasons
it's different are many we explain them
in that CPU piece but as a couple
examples uh where the bottleneck is can
change the efficiency so Shifting the
load more to the CPU to where the GPU
can't even fully stretch its legs that
doesn't necessarily increase the
efficiency and in fact can instead hurt
it we saw this with the CPU test too
where even when we were GPU bound the
CPU was still having to to burn at
fairly High wattage just to keep the GPU
supplied with frames to render now FPS
per watt with gpus produces mostly sub
1.0 numbers and that's just because the
power consumption is higher than
typically the frame rate is in terms of
pure numerical value for what we're
looking at today uh it doesn't
particularly mean or affect anything
it's just that you might ask well why
not watts per FPS as an example then you
get a nice positive number maybe it's
10.5 or something as opposed to
0.47 and the only real answer we have
for that is just consistency we're just
going with FPS per watt because we
already used it for the CPU one people
seem familiar with it they seem to like
it and the response from you all was
positive uh however if everyone would
prefer to see watts per FPS we could do
that too it's kind of all the same it
doesn't really matter at the end of the
day but also FPS per wat allows us to go
for a bigger number better and as we all
know thanks to Intel bigger number
better means better number gets more
bigger better so that's better because
it's bigger let's get started Starfield
at 4K starts us off for efficiency in
this one the most efficient card in the
test was the RTX 480 at 0.27 FPS per
watt or if you want to look at it
another way about 3.7 Watts per FPS or
in another way still 0.27 frames per
jeel there are a lot of options here the
4070 TI super is about equal with the
original 470 TI the latter of which
technically has a 2.1% Improvement in
efficiency here compared to the 7900 XT
the 4070 TI super is about 4% more
efficient in fps per watt at 1440p the
490 slips down the ranks a bit more as
it approaches a CPU bind this reveals
interesting data that shows that
although the CPU may start limiting
performance that doesn't necessarily
make the GPU more efficient it's similar
to the IOD Baseline power requirement
buffer that we saw for AMD CPUs in the
past efficiency test anyway the 4070 TI
super again allows the 4070 TI El lead
in efficiency This Time by about 4.1%
the 4070 TI super lead over the 7800 XT
is relatively large 15% here showing
that AMD is trading power for
performance at 1080p the 480 Remains the
most efficient while the 490 continues
to slip down the ranks its Baseline
power requirement to maintain operation
with its default settings as in the card
settings is reducing its efficiency as
it gets increasingly Tangled Up by other
components this is really interesting
data and it implies that the entire
system will in fact be less efficient as
CPU load increases as we saw in our
previous CPU efficiency test or at least
in the scenarios we've benchmarked so
far the 4070 TI super produced 0.57 FPS
per watt here that has the 4070 TI
original card 4.4% more efficient or the
4070 TI super as 25% more efficient than
the 7800 XT the 7800 XT is also becoming
limited causing a further Gulf so let's
unbind it in Resident Evil 4 at 4K
without RT we found the 4070 TI to be
the least efficient card with the 4070
TI super improving by 6% it could be the
case that the uplift in this title comes
from the memory subsystem change as
opposed to frequency the 7800 XT is
significantly more efficient here due to
overall higher performance than
previously allowing it to roughly tie
the R TX 480 the 7800 XT sits between
the ti super and the original TI at
1440p the 470 TI super still leads the
470 TI Now by about 2.7% so it's reduced
with the 7800 XT still relatively high
up on the chart the 470 super ends up
striking the strongest balance overall
on this one at 1080p the 480 and the
7900 XT still have some scaling Headroom
for frame rate the90s overall
comparative efficiency has fallen but it
still pulls 357 watts and it remains
It's relatively heavily loaded despite
being limited on total CPU scale the
4070 TI super is roughly tied with the
4070 TI at this resolution so it's lead
shrank with each resolution decrease the
7800 XT allows the 47 TI super a lead of
1.4% so they're about tied and the 470
super strikes the best balance so far
once again in Rainbow Six Siege at 4K
the RTX 480 Remains the most efficient
of the group followed by the 470 super
which is now establishing a trend and
then the 490 the 490 is slightly lower
on the efficiency curve for volt
frequency tuning to maximize performance
the 4070 TI super leads the 4070 TI by
8.3% in this title a result of the
average FPS increase being higher than
we've seen in some other games where
that 8.3% lead is for efficiency the 700
XT ends up between the two TI class
cards now we're going to quickly look at
some 10p and 30p point non-c consecutive
highs from the entire test run including
loading screens in this chart we're
looking at just Watts the 490 pulled 52
Watts for its average on the highest 10
points of data with 498 Watts for the
highest 30 points averaged this won't
capture the smallest transin which will
Spike higher still but that's something
we looked at in the past the 700 XT
pulled 385 Watts as it's 10o high with
the 470 TI super at 330 watts to the
TI's 321 watts and Starfield at 1440p
that drops to 382 Watts on the 700 XT
372 on the 490 which is becoming CPU
constrained and 26 6 6 on the 4070 TI
super the 480 shows why it was so power
efficient here so that's the foundation
of efficiency testing I am really
excited to see where this goes we put
this together just in the last week so
uh again there's a lot that can be
changed there's a lot we can improve
we're aware of it this is nowhere near
sort of like the perfect end game of how
we want to represent this but it's an
initial representation gives you some
ideas to play around with Post in the
comments and we'll keep tweaking it as
well and post a separate Standalone
piece as we continue to figure it out
but um we did this just in the last week
alongside adding cyberpunk rage tracing
and starting to explore Allen wake 2
testing so there's a lot going on for
our GPU reviews but of all of that we
think the GPU efficiency stuff is going
to be the most interesting and promising
anyway we'll start with some game
Benchmark summary charts and then we'll
get into the individual game benchmarks
here's a summary chart of the 4070 TI
super versus the 4070 TI nons super non
non-ti the bars indicate percent
Improvement by moving two the 4070 TI
super from the 4070 TI in general we're
seeing about a 10 to 11% uplift at 4K
our testing tends to be at highly
intensive settings to minimize CPU load
so especially when at 4K this makes
sense with the memory subsystem and
frame BFF for improvement two of the
older games here Horizon zero Dawn and
Total War Warhammer 3 posted gains
higher than we saw in other titles on
this chart at 1440p we saw about a 7%
average or so uplift in the 470 TI super
versus the 470 TI that's not
particularly exciting it reduces from
the 4K gains because the memory just
isn't as impactful at 1080p we typically
saw from 2% to 6% gains with a few
breakouts higher generally speaking it's
call it about 5% or so uplift at 1080p
now we have two identical 4070 TI Super
Cards the tough models and so we also
decided to run these through Port Royal
for frequency validation the brief test
established an average frequency 2746
MHz for the unit we tested for our
review with the more recently tested
unit that wasn't used in the review
today at 2725 MHz this is about a 20 MHz
or so Delta it's within manufacturing
variants but the Silicon quality on the
unit we chose at random appears to be a
little higher than the secondary model
and obviously the one that ran 20 MHz
higher smelled freshly of leather
jackets handpicked definitely a golden
sample that was SAR
ASM but someone was typing it it'll SN
it a little bit though but let's move on
to the 7900 XT versus the 4070 TI we
broke this into RT and non-rt charts
because the scale slides opposing
directions and we'd prefer to do as much
of that math in a single direction or
percent Improvement as possible that
just keeps it cleaner now that said when
you're talking about a percentage Point
change of
0.5 between going positive or negative
Direction the impact isn't that big
regardless but we are trying to keep it
all showing as much as possible in
percent Improvement regardless the RT
performance strongly benefits the 4070
TI super we noticed that cyberpunk
scales insanely in favor of Nvidia as
all graphic settings increase with
customized ultra settings without
upscaling pushing the ti super in the
range of 70 plus% for its lead over the
7900 XT with cyberpunk using medium
settings instead but still RT we saw the
gains have down to something like 35%
for the 4070 TI super over the 700 XD as
a workload for RT amplifies the favor
for NVIDIA likewise seems to
disproportionately amplify in less
intensive RT scenarios the lead is often
below 20% there's one 4K upscaled result
favoring the 7900 XT in Resident Evil 4
which progressively moves toward Nvidia
favor as the resolution decreases in
non-rt workload switching the chart to
show to the 7900 XT from the 4070 TI
super we see that 7900 XT starts pulling
ahead on average depending on resolution
it's anywhere from equal to 14% ahead
with losses toward the bottom of the
chart time to move into specific game
Benchmark charts we have a lot of cards
on here so depending on which chart you
look at goes back to the 2070 uh there's
1080ti in there 3060 variants are in
there uh 6600 variants are in there it
depends on the resolution but there's a
lot to look at so feel free to pause for
the specific card you might have and if
your specific card is not there remember
you can go and grab a a reference to a
card that is on our charts with a known
percent difference from that card and
you can start kind of calculating it
roughly on your own it's not perfect but
I'll get you pretty close to it okay
let's get into those charts Starfield is
up next another of our 2023 titles with
2024 patches to test at 4K the RTX 470
TI super landed at 62 FPS average with
lows proportional and well timed that
has it ahead of the 4070 TI by
relatively uneventful 6.3% the lead over
the 4070 super is 18% and compared to
some cards you might upgrade from it's
ordered as follows 79% over the 3070 and
161% over the 2070 the RX 7900 XT leads
the 470 TI super by 10% here so AMD is
still leveraging its advantage in this
particular game and has a wider lead
than it does in some others and just for
reference the 490 leads the 4070 TI
super by 47% here at 92 FPS average if
you were curious what that jump would do
at 1440p the 4070 TI super still has
full scaling in this Benchmark its lead
over the nons super variant 95 FPS
average is just 4.4% now down from the
already low 6% at 4K and the ti super
now only leads the 470 super by 14.7% so
it's even less exciting than before
let's move on Resident Evil 4 is another
2023 game that we've added recently and
this one tested at 4K and rasterized
first the 4070 TI super ran at 87 FPS
average and led the 4070 TI by 10. 6%
with the 7800 XT leading the ti super by
12% 480 is just ahead of that looking
down the stack the 6800 XT remains one
of the most powerful and viable options
at the $500 Mark that's assuming it's
still there when this goes up although
it's not the most viable in every game
on the Nvidia side the ti super leads
the new RTX 470 Sans TI super at 71 FPS
for that 4070 super by 23% over possible
upgrade Pathways the lead over the 3070
the 20 70 non super and the 2080 is
significant respectively at 86% 190% on
the 2070 and 139% on the 2080 scaling is
clean at 1440p lows are proportional so
since the 0.1% lows don't indicate
anything noteworthy here we've removed
them to instead accommodate more gpus on
this chart that's the trade-off the 470
TI super is 172 FPS average as at 7.8%
ahead of the 4070 TI reduced from the
10.6% result at 4K scaling Titans as
resolution fall for these two the 4070
TI super is still bed by the 7800 XT
here this time by 6.8% this chart added
a bunch of mid-range cards from ages
past so for some potential Pathways
there's the RX 6600 shown at 58 FPS
average the 6600 XT at 70 and the 360 at
57 FPS average with the 360 TI at 78
respectively these would SE Improvement
of 200% on the 6600 147% on the 66 XT
and then 2011% and 121% for the 2360
class cards at 1080p the 4070 TI super
is still scaling with the CPU it's at
253 FPS average leading the 470 TI by
5.1% predictably less than at 1440p and
4K the 7800 xt's lead also reduces here
down to 3.4% d light 2 is a 2022 game
that's up now tested at 4K first the
4070 TI super leads the 470 TI by 12.6%
better than we saw in the last game the
700 XT is about equal with the 4070 TI
super and can't be told apart at a
functional level owners of the 2070 nons
super would see massive gains under
these test conditions at about
178% a lot of that is from the Intensive
4K load that the 2070 is struggling with
the 2080 would likewise get multiples of
uplift alternatives to the 4070 TI super
might include the 7800 XT at equivalent
performance or the 470 super at reduced
performance but it still achieves 83% of
the performance of the ti super the 6800
XT would be another option here and is
one that has aged relatively well with
its price drops up next 1440p 0.1% lows
scaled perfectly fine with this there
were no abnormalities so we removed them
to permit space for more cards on the
chart this includes fresh retest of the
6600 the 6600 XT and the 6700 XT in this
test the 470 TI suers lead over the 470
TI is reduced to 8.4% with gains against
the 6600 XT and 6600 at 152% and 197%
respectively mentioned just in case
that's something you're considering
upgrading from Alternatives still
include the 700 XT ahead by 3.1% and the
480 more meaningfully ahead but we would
strongly advise against a 480 given the
480 sup is inbound status in basically a
week and lower price and the 470 super
is another alternative at 85% of the
performance of the 4070 TI super at
1080p the 4070 TI supers lead over the
the 4070 TI is now even lower at 5.8%
the 700 XT is tied so its lead has also
Fallen scaling is clean from a testing
standpoint just that this isn't
particularly interesting so let's move
forward now we're moving on to our set
of benchmarks that we keep around for
reliability and long-term validation
because the numbers rarely change for
these so it's easier to keep a huge
amount of cards on the charts in Tomb
Raider at 4K the 4070 TI super tough
leads the 4070 TI by 12% in this regard
it's roughly Tied by the 7 00 XT for
upgrade references the lead over the
2070 XC is 167% it's the same over the
6600 XT and the RTX 3060 XC at 1440p the
4070 TI super led the 470 TI by 85%
posting full scaling with the lead over
the new 4070 super at about
16.5% compared to older generation cards
you might upgrade from options include a
doubling over the RTX 360 TI and RTX
2080 a 171 1% boost over the 6600 non XT
at 82 FPS and similar over the original
RTX 360 in f-122 at 4K the RTX 470 TI
super ran at 137 FPS average leading the
470 TI by 11% that has the 7800 XT ahead
of the 4070 TI super by
8.7% and the 480 is just past that
compared to upgrade options the lead of
the 4070 TI super over the 2070 XC is
163% against the 52 FPS average result
it's about the same Boost from the 6600
XD and 360 XC Alternatives might include
the 4070 super which achieves 82% of the
performance of the ti super for 75% of
the price or the 6800 XT which achieves
84% of the performance for 63% of the
cost in this game although that changes
with rt at 1440p the 4070 TI super post
full scaling at 228 FPS average leading
the 470 TI by 6. . 3% reduction against
4K despite Unbound scaling the 7800 XT
is closer to the 480 than the ti super
meanwhile the 470 super gives the ti
super a 15% lead bringing upgrades back
into the picture the 1080 TI would gain
more than double the frame rate although
the 108ti is still plenty good for a lot
of rasterized games RX 6600 users would
jump 167% from 86 FPS average we're
still not CPU bound at 1080p for the 407
TI super the ti super leads the ti by
5.8% now down again and the 470 super by
12% the 700xt has climbed the ranks a
little and established a 14% lead over
the 4070 TI super revisiting those
upgrade options the 2070 was down at
around 120 FPS average so there'd be a
huge boost here with the 3060 at 126 FPS
average the 1080t at 142 and the 6600 XT
at 152 FPS average in any of those scen
scenarios the ti super would be a big
jump with rt jumping even more whether
or not that's worth it really depends on
the games you play and if you notice
that your card is feeling slow if you're
not playing heavier newer games it's
obviously less likely to be critical
Rainbow Six Siege is up now we ran
efficiency tests for this earlier but
remember the FPS numbers aren't taken
from this chart they were tested
separately with the background tasks the
4070 TI sup 184 FPS average had it 10%
ahead of the 4070 TI and 21% ahead of
the 407 super the AMD 7900 XT puts up a
strong fight here technically anyway but
it's not particularly noticeable it does
however outpace the 470 TI super price
is what'll matter there compared to the
2070 super at 84 FPS average we're seing
a 120% Improvement in the ti super the
3060 isn't distant from that math down
at 71 FPS average 1440p reduces the ti
Super's lead to just 3 and a half% over
the 4070 TI an unexciting move the 7900
XTX and 490 indicate that we still have
plenty of CPU Headroom so this is an
unfortunately real and boring change
from the 4070 TI there's no point
spending more time here it doesn't
meaningfully move the needle from the
4070 TI it's boring and it certainly
arrests the price of the card at the
$800 Mark Final Fantasy 14 is up now
first at 4K the 470 TI super ran at 129
FPS average here establishing a 15 FPS
lead over the 4070 TI or about 12.5% the
7800 XT sits close to the ti super but
behind it and AMD has worst .1% lows in
this game then would be proportional to
the average against the 470 super the ti
super is 23% better and against the
Baseline 2070 it's 178% improved we
haven't retested it in a while but the
RTX 2060 is on this chart as a point of
reference its frame rate may have moved
slightly in the past year generally
speaking though we don't see meaningful
gaps to developed with this game at this
point which is why it's here finally for
the Old Reliable benchmarks GTA 5 at 4K
has the 4070 TI super at 140 FPS average
leading the 4070 TI by 11.6% and the 470
super by 19% if you bought an RTX 26d
when it launched an upgrade here would
yield a 185% uplift the 7900 XT is just
behind the ti super here as well we'll
open our rate tracing testing with
cyberpunk Phantom Liberty which was only
just added to the test suite and
therefore has fewer cars than the RT
test we'll look at after it we're
iterating and adding to this each review
and we'll keep adding new types of tests
too as we continue to do more reviews
all of these tests were conducted in the
last two days and were done across two
groups of settings the first batch uses
RT Ultra with upscaling disabled Ray
reconstruction disabled and overdrive
off the second batch uses a much lighter
RT medium which we found to have lower
scaling impact overall and more
favorable but still weak AMD performance
and these performance deficit widens as
RT load increases and again upscaling is
off for both of these here's the chart
at 4K first the 4070 TI super ran at
about 23 FPS average this average is low
but the lows are spaced proportionally
and well as compared to the average
despite being unplayable this is a good
academic study of bandwidth and why we
included this test the 4070 TI ran at
20.6 FPS average allowing the ti super a
lead of 133% that breaks rank from some
of the others we've seen critically the
original TI has significantly worse lows
here you wouldn't use these settings for
either card but it does show that the
memory bandwidth and capacity change
influenced the performance in some key
areas the closest AMD card here is the
7800 XTX which underperformed against
the 4070 super but held stronger lows at
1440p Ultra the 4070 TI Super's lead
over the 4070 TI drops to 8% the cards
diverge as load increases as a result of
the memory subsystem changes so it does
in fact do something but the impact
becomes largely academic since we were
in unplayable territory at 4K Ultra the
7800 XTX runs below the 4070 super here
the 490 posts a massive lead of 58% over
the 470 TI super just to set the ceiling
at 1080p Ultra the 470 TI Super's lead
was reduced to 6% the memory subsystem
overhaul doesn't matter much here it's
not as heavily loaded as at 4K the 480
leads by 15% here with the 7800 XTX
still tied with the 470 look at RT
medium briefly here the 4070 TI super
lead the ti by 12% at 57.7 to 51.6 the
7800 XTX is much more competitive here
than it was at Ultra now surpassing the
470 super and roughly tying with the 470
TI it's still not competitive on the
whole in this test but this illustrates
that heavier RT loads disproportionately
separate AMD and Nvidia favoring Nvidia
as RT workload goes higher finally at
1080p medium the 4070 TI super leads the
4070 TI by 7% the lowest of this game in
settings so far the 7800 XTX is about
equal with the 470 super here with the
XT about equal to the 470 and's relative
rank overall has fallen at this
resolution it's benefited by the higher
resolution combination with lower rate
tracing settings in Resident Evil 4 with
rate tracing and at 4K we're using FSR
as a test of both upscaling and RT
impact we measured the 4070 TI Supra at
101 FPS average here leading the 4070 TI
by 11% the 700xt manages to outperform
the 470 super in this one although that
doesn't persist to heavier RT games like
cyberpunk as we saw earlier compared to
the 4070 super the ti super is about 22%
better and compared to the older 2070
back when RTX was new it's about 150%
better at 1440p the 4070 TI super runs
at 165 FPS average with upscaling and RT
that has it just ahead of the 7800 XT
and 7.7% ahead of the 4070 TI finally
for Resident Evil RT 1080p has the 47 TI
super at 2011 FPS average with FSR
reducing the lead over the ti original
to 5.7% the 7900 XT sits closer at this
point to the original 4070 TI than the
4070 TI super but overall it's between
them in dlight 2 with r tracing and
equivalent upscaling between all the
vendors we saw the 4070 TI super at 51.8
FPS average leading the 4070 TI by just
9% the 700 XT Trails the 4070 super here
down at 38 FPS a average and just ahead
of the 4070 Baseline card so the XT is
not in a great spot competitively Nvidia
is advantaged it's not as Extreme as in
cyberp Punk or Allen wake 2 but it's
definitely more than in Resident Evil 4
generationally the 470 TI super leads
the 370 by 86% and the RTX 2080 by 182%
at 1440p we've added some mid-range past
gen cards to the list the RTX 2070 now
appears down at 30 FPS PS average ahead
of the 6600 xt's 27 FPS average result
and behind the 3060 TI's 46 result the
4070 TI super is 96 FPS average leads
the 4070 TI by about 7% so it's dropping
once again the 700xt is behind the 380
and the 4070 super in this one and ahead
of the 4070 it's not competing with the
ti class cards directly at 1080p the
4070 TI super lead over the 4070 TI is
reduced to just 4.4% the 7800 XT is
about 5 to 6% ahead of the 470 and it
continues to yield an advantage to
Nvidia not much has changed for these
ranks finally we're on power although we
looked at Power efficiency earlier now
we'll briefly look at our standardized
total power consumption against more
cards the 4070 TI super tough card
pulled 291 Watts with the Quiet bios or
296 Watts with the default performance
feed bios that are shipped in
overclocking allows a maximum power
consumption of 321 Watts with the OC on
the performance bios the 296 watt figure
has it about the same as a 6800 XT and
less than an RX 7900 XT by 10 to 25
watts depending on which card you look
at the 4070 TI was about 5 Watts less at
290 watts in our original testing and
that contributes to some of the
performance Gap as well well it's a lot
of numbers first on our side of things
we're excited not because of this this
is like we'll talk about it we're
excited because the efficiency testing
the latency stuff's really cool um it's
coming back in for the 480 super like
stated but we wanted to kind of get the
efficiency stuff in this one so we're
experimenting with a couple different
approaches to reviewing gpus that aren't
just frame rate which is what we've
historically done there's obviously uh
plenty of different approaches out there
but our primary focus has been frame
times frame pacing frame rate and then
power in total uh power consumption
workloads like power virus so we're
overhauling that and uh the efficiency
stuff I'm personally really excited
about now uh as for the rest of this so
for the cards you have all the numbers
we'll let you make your own decision but
if you want some stances on it as
briefly as possible uh this launch can
largely be summed up with a very
Advanced
word me it's really not particularly
strong but it's also not offensively bad
the price is locked so probably the
worst or biggest downside there is is
that we might traditionally have
received the price cut here with the ti
but instead the ASP or the average
selling price remains up as a result of
this launch but the performance also
goes up a little bit with it and so
we're back to me it's not the the worst
a card could receive on this channel
it's just kind of in the middle so it
seems like Nvidia as we said in the
beginning has chosen to couch this car
in the middle of maybe two more
interesting launches but especially the
480 super uh looks interesting now that
said we haven't tested it yet so we'll
see we'll know how that pans out
somewhere around January 31st or so as
when it's supposed to be launching so
reviews plus or minus day on that but
the 4070 TI super puts pressure on AMD
7900 xte if you care a lot about Super
heavy rage tracing like Ultra or high
settings in games like cyberp Punk or
Allen wake then that's where the
difference really starts to appear and
you've also got things like Ray
reconstruction to consider uh that is
basically entirely subjective we have a
separate video on that where we just
show you the uh A and B comparison for
it if you don't care about Ray tracing
or you play games that are Ray traced
but typically with something like a
single RT feature Shadows Reflections
things like that but not typically
combined or generally lower uh RT
intensity then the 7900 XT remains a
good consideration especially because of
its new found price
drops little hesitant to commit to
calling a particular price for it right
now cuz it's kind of in flux but the
last we checked for Hardware news uh
there's evidence of it on New Egg it was
like 710 bucks uh sometimes 750 but 710
seem to be starting to become at least
available in the US North American
market so anyway that's been changing a
lot it's largely going to come down the
price on those and if you care about RT
or particularly heavy RT like uh as high
settings as you might be able to
realistically set with a particular card
but that'll be it for the review You've
got a lot of numbers to work with and
make a choice on it um we've been
experimenting with totally over hauling
the test one Benchmark at a time so next
one we're hoping to bring the latency
back in we debuted again the 70 super uh
we've got some changes we're do into
that to further improve it hopefully
make it even more useful and explain it
some more further and then we also have
the 7600 XT review next it is about 30
hours be well just give everyone some
perspective uh it's less than 12 hours
before this review has to go live so I
need to finish editing the rest of it uh
and then I need need to start writing
the 7600 XT which will go up 24 hours
after that
so see you soon and otherwise the 480
super should be the one where we have
about a week to work on it so check back
for that as well okay we'll see you all
tomorrow about 24 hours I think I don't
I don't know thanks for watching as
always go to store. Gamers access.net
grab one of these shirts to support our
in-depth testing efforts and our
overhauls and and you can go to
patreon.com Gamers ACC helps out
directly we'll see you all next time